réfléchir sur son avenir professionnel à
la lueur des bougies
c'est le concept proposé depuis 2012 par
le service jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux différents pôles
d'information ont permis aux élèves mais
aussi à leurs parents d'y voir plus
clair
c'est très compliqué en plus nous on a
quitté une école ya déjà un moment donc
on connaît moins les écoles les filières
d'aujourd'hui dans l'informatique par
exemple beaucoup de nouveaux métiers
sont créés et qu'on ne connaît pas donc
c'est pas évident pour nous de pouvoir
les aider les aiguilles souvent il ya
une part d'angoise autour de
l'orientation le fait d'être accompagné
par des professionnels ça
ça permet de dédramatiser un petit peu
et de prendre le temps
au programme conférences pour mieux
connaître les dates clés de
l'orientation stands de découverte des
métiers et de formations possibles sur
notre territoire les plus indécis
pouvait effectuer des tests
d'orientation en ligne
je me dis que si je sais pas trop quoi
faire assez vite va au mes études
sérieuses être compliqué autre
inquiétude pour les élèves et notamment
les terminales les inscriptions depuis
la semaine dernière sur parcours sup la
plateforme d'admission postbac ce qu'il
faut le redire c'est aujourd'hui vous
devez faire un choix qui est difficile
mais par rapport à qui vous êtes
maintenant peut-être les 6,5 10 ans on
ne serait plus la même personne n'aurait
plus mêmes objectifs et du coup vous
aurez le droit de changer concernant
parcours sup les élèves ont jusqu'au 12
mars pour saisir leurs voeux